- Hallo, junger Mann.
Wo kommst du denn jetzt her?
- Ich war draußen. Ich habe
meine Tasche gefunden.
- Hat die Polizei deine Tasche gefunden?
- Nein, Selma.
- Oho, wer ist denn Selma?
- Niemand …
- Komm mal mit. Ich habe eine
tolle Überraschung für dich.
- Eine Überraschung? Was?
- Das sind Sachen von Günther.
Günther war mein Mann.
Er lebt nicht mehr.
Er hat immer sehr elegante
Kleidung getragen.
Alles ist so gut wie neu.
Schau mal, dieses schicke Hemd!
Und die braune Hose steht
dir sicher sehr gut.
- Sieht bequem aus.
- Na los, probier die Sachen an!
Ich finde, du bist ein hübscher
junger Mann!
Das steht dir ganz toll.
Sehr elegant.
Ein gestreiftes Hemd und eine warme
Hose und ganz schicke Schuhe!
- Na ja, ich weiß nicht.
- Wer ist das denn?
Hallo?
- Hallo, ich bin die Selma. Ist Nico da?